maybe you've seen the pictures it's a
yellow organism it looks a bit like a
fern or maybe a coral or maybe a moss
but really it's something called a slime
mold and when the pairs Zoological Park
put one on display recently calling it
the blob the internet got itself in a
tizzy it may look simple but this
brainless organism can actually make
decisions and solve mazes to learn more
we sat down with mycologist and Pringle
at the University of Wisconsin
what is this quote-unquote blob species
of slime mold people are calling Pfizer
I'm Polly suckling the blob and it's a
species it's not a plant it's not an
animal it's not a fungus outside of
those three kingdoms that we're really
familiar with there are all these other
kinds of organisms a lot of different
groups that were just less familiar with
but they're really diverse they play
important roles in our environment and
buys Arum is characterized by this part
of its lifecycle called the Plasmodium
which is basically a giant enormous cell
I like this idea of a slime mold as
completely defying human expectations
and I guess by extension befuddling the
Internet of late it was that surprising
that all this all of us in the Paris zoo
put this on display and it just blew up
for me it's exciting it gives lots of
people lots of opportunities to talk
about a subject that you know gosh when
I go to a cocktail party I'm not sure a
lot of people really want to hear about
buy serum or at least it takes a while
to get into it and and having the
parents do and I don't know who made
that decision or how they
but it feels brilliant to me to be able
to put something so different out there
and say gosh look at it you know what is
it how do we think about it how do we
talk about it and no I'm not surprised I
think when when I teach my class on
biology of the fungi there are a few
comments that I consistently get one
comment is I see them all the time now
you know in a way that you can't see it
unless you're taught to see it and so if
you're taught to see it then all of a
sudden everywhere you go there's a
fungus which is true everywhere you go
there is a fungus and then a strong
reaction I get is amazement how did I
not know this before how come no one
told me about this before so I'm not
surprised by that that reaction and it's
also pretty fun to watch it play out is
it particularly rare and where do you
find it there are lots of species of 5-0
more than 100 and if you went to your
local woods and it was the right time of
year and they're moist habitat you'd
absolutely find it yourself
most people think of a cell is this
really tiny thing you can't see if this
is a one giant cell you walk us through
how it operates as one big cell with
many many nuclei within we understand
some answers to that question and there
are other things that we don't know so
we do know that there are no cross walls
no septa no barriers of any kind inside
that giant cell so fluids can flow
across the body very easily and that's
obviously really different from us this
is a very very tiny Plasmodium and a
drop of water just got put on the right
hand side and now can you see this
rhythmic contraction yes and then
there's another drop but that's food can
you see the the tip swelling and then
just watch and you'll see waves pulsing
across the body
so those waves are caused by peristalsis
which is basically rhythmic contraction
expansion contraction expansion
contraction expansion that moves fluids
and we think information across the body
how Phi's Arum communicates across
itself how it integrates information and
coordinates behavior has to do with some
kind of signaling molecule that's
propagated
in a very particular way what that
signaling molecule is it might be
calcium it might be something else can
we talk about how the organism is in a
sense exploring its environment in the
way that it's almost pathfinding in an
environment it is pathfinding and i
think that's part of the the buzz around
it right people hear about it and they
hear things like it has so many sexes
and it forages and that's our really
that comes across is a really remarkable
behavior and I think that's because we
tend to associate a word like behavior
with something like a dog or an animal
but here clearly there's an organism
that's moving around and it's foraging
right it's it's sensing in its
environment for example where there are
resource rich patches it doesn't have
eyes it doesn't have the kind of sensory
apparatus that we're used to and so in
some sense it's foraging has to do with
sending out tendrils if you will or
parts of itself to explore the
surrounding habitat and that's really
what it's doing and all of these
experiments that have to do with getting
fuzzy room to grow in particular ways
mimic the optimal network that would
connect the rail stations of Tokyo or
state capitals of the United States or
etc it's really growing across a lot of
space and then it's reorganizing itself
into a configuration that allows it to
optimally eat and eventually optimally
reproduce I don't know it's hard to talk
about intelligence and with an animal
like this school we have so many
concepts around intelligence we base it
so much on humans and other animals but
you know this isn't like it it knows
it's in a maze it's gonna solve the maze
it's doing what it would typically do in
a natural environment
it absolutely is doing what it would
typically do in a natural environment
when people think about fuzzy I'm
solving a maze but a lot of people think
fuzz aaron is doing is solving the maze
the way you or I would solve a maze it
starts at Point a it finds the shortest
route through the maze and it reaches
point B that's not what fuzzy M is doing
why as Aaron grows through the entire
maze it searches all that space then it
retracts
six body just to the shortest path so
that's a really different way of
quote-unquote solving a maze then what
we tend to think about and I think
that's a really important distinction I
find the word intelligence really
problematic like the word sex just
because both words are so loaded with
meaning and with meaning that has
nothing to do with you know the biology
of fungi or fungal like organisms when
we talk about sex and by theorem first
of all there 5mm has a really complex
life cycle or more complex than we're
used to as as humans and in a different
part of the life cycle there are single
cells called swarm cells those are the
cells that when mating happens they fuse
and they fuse to become one body so I
love my husband very much but when we
got married we did not fuse into a
single body my body is here his body is
over in his office so it's a really
different kind of process and we're
talking about mating for as Arum and
basically whether or not two cells can
fuse and form one body has to do with
three genes and one of the genes there
are sixteen Llosa at least sixteen and
another there are fifteen and another
there are three so if you multiply 16
times 15 times 3 you get 720 possible
combinations and that's the that's the
start of this idea that it has more than
700 sexes and then the giant Plasmodium
when it reproduces it actually the whole
body turns into spores that then
disperse on the wind it's just a very
different path so you know outside of a
maze in a natural environment what are
these organisms actually eating so in
the lab we needed quick roads and it
seems to like though it's very much and
it actually seems to eat the oats and
digest them down it's a little bits and
discard bits a bit out of its body in
nature we think that it's it's hoovering
up bacteria and fungal spores and other
really small creatures that are on the
substrates the rock or the woods or the
mulch that it's growing on and engulfing
them where exactly in the Tree of Life
to these organisms spend imagine that
you were back in a time where you were
just looking at organisms grouping
organisms according to what they looked
like then you would quite reasonably
look at a look at a fight there and look
at a slime mold and say gosh it looks a
lot like a fungus and then something
comes along called the PCR machine right
and we can start sequencing DNA and when
you start sequencing DNA there's a
massive rearrangement in our
understanding of how things are related
to each other and so we begin to
understand that that slime molds are not
the true fungi as we call them even
though they're fungal like organisms but
there's something really apart and so at
this point I would say it's one of the
most exciting areas of biology is we
know what plants are more or less we
understand what animals are more or less
fungi and maybe less than more but we
think we know what fungi are but then
there are all these groups of organisms
that aren't any of those three and even
more interestingly we don't have a sense
of their biodiversity there are very few
people who study the biodiversity of
slime molds it's genuinely fun to talk
about this stuff also because I think
the language around intelligence and
maze solving is fantastic in its own way
but for me it also just becomes a a tool
to talk about some much larger issues
about biodiversity and what do we know
about this earth that we're living on
and what do we not know and to me it
seems like we don't know quite a lot and
if you fantastic to have more people
involved and thinking about how many
slime molds are there in my woods gosh
is it a local fuzzy room you know etc so
it's it seems the real opportunity thank
you for being here and bringing up all
these crazy philosophical questions
about a seemingly simple organism my
pleasure